hey youtubers its charlie this video is
gonna be all about brands flash bags
what they are what's going on and what
they're using them for during season six
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far quick
refresher bran is a green seer he is
learning from another green seer the
Bloodraven also known as the three-eyed
Raven who's a really big figure in
Westerosi history that we'll talk about
in a second but we've seen him do a
number of different things on the show
we've seen him warg into summer and
Hodor we've seen him travel back in time
we've seen him project himself astrally
across space and time so there's a lot
more to greensight that bran hasn't
learned yet that we'll probably get to
see is the rest of the season goes on
but it's a much more broad-based power
over nature that ties back to the
children of the forest all of the
children of the forest by default are
born with the powers that greenseers
have greenseers are what you call a
human being that's born with those
powers in this it's like 1 in every
1,000 wargs is born a green seer so if a
fraction of the population is born with
working abilities then a fraction of
that population are born green seers
which is why they called the Bloodraven
before bran came along the last green
seer and in the books he's about 200
years old
the TV shows doing a couple different
things with the timeline so we'll just
have to adjust depending on how they
explained things but the big disclaimer
and I probably should have said this at
the beginning of the video is that as
the seasons of the show get on they're
departing from the books more and more
so I think a lot of the big conclusions
that they draw will be very similar to
the conclusions that we reach in the
books but the way they get there will be
different and there might actually be a
couple of different things like when
they make a big reveal on the TV show it
might go down very differently in the
books so depending on the things that we
happen and the big twist and the plot
we'll just have to remember that like
there might be a little bit different
when we actually get wins a winner
because they're starting to see more and
more like that book isn't gonna drop to
the Christmas shopping season this year
there hasn't been any marketing
materials for winds of winter so I'm
just assuming at this point we're not
gonna see it till much later this year
so we've learned in the first couple of
episodes that bran can astrally project
himself into the past he has a loose
ability to connect with people in those
scenes like they can actually hear what
he says just a little bit so there is a
bit of a bleed effect and we actually
have seen the night's king in the
trailer
grab his arm but all I think that means
is they're implying there's this loose
connection that everything has across
space and time so even if bran is seeing
the night's king in the past and he
grabs him that doesn't mean that brain
is physically in the past it seems more
like the night's king is also projecting
himself astrally across space and time
so they're kind of interacting with each
other in this astral sense I don't
expect them to do it but the real test
would be if Ned started like young Ned
Stark could reach out and grab brand
then we would know for sure but just
remember the idea that everything is
connected so things can bleed through
brand from present to past there are a
lot of people that have wondered you
know maybe there's a crazy theory that
the Mad King went mad because Brand
derped while he was actually projecting
so maybe bran inadvertently set off
Robert's rebellion it's kind of an
outlandish theory but I do think that
they're going to pay off most of
Robert's rebellion in brans flashbacks
which kind of a double-edged sword
because I know a lot of people want a
prequel set during Robert's rebellion
like if HBO is gonna do a spin-off
series you know maybe they do Robert's
rebellion that's a whole other thing and
I think they'd actually be better off
doing Duncan egg or something like that
but it seems like we're actually getting
the story of Robert's rebellion through
brands flashbacks broken up across the
season so that probably means they're
gonna save the biggest reveals for the
last episode so just plan for them to
stretch everything out across all ten
episodes of this season right now it
seems like it's a relatively
disconnected plot like bran stuff all
exists on its own but they're starting
to weave it in with modern days that
like bran is largely by himself
so all these flashbacks all the things
he's learning about haven't really
affected the other main characters yet
like the things that he has learned
hasn't directly affected Jon Snow yet
but it seems like eventually that's
where it's headed because if Daenerys is
going to come to Westeros with her army
how is she going to learn about the
White Walkers well most of what we've
learned about everything comes through
bran
so bran would probably be the person to
explain it all look you've heard a lot
of stories but I actually saw it I went
back and saw it
so the flashbacks have become the show's
way of saying look all the stories
you've heard about all these things are
wrong people have been telling it wrong
I know the real truth never has that
been more clear than with Melisandre
storyline she thought that Stannis was
the one who has promised that went
sideways then
Jon Snow is resurrected oh wow you are
very clearly the prince who was promised
that's a whole other thing too we'll
have to talk about as we get more
evidence because the way that that
prophecy is interpreted is a little
derpy because originally it was written
in high Valyrian which is gender-neutral
so a lot of people think that Daenerys
might be the prince who was promised
because the term Prince is very gender
specific and that didn't exist in the
original Valyrian passage so it's a bit
of a misinterpretation so there is a lot
of misinterpretation when it comes to
the past and prophecies the show is now
using the flashbacks to throw water on
or to clarify look this is what really
happened so you have all this setup in
the bran flashbacks Hodor
you can talk what happened to you then
as the season gets on it slowly pays
those things off who's in that tower who
is that woman screaming what's going on
so the really important thing about
these flashbacks you guys need to pay
attention to is that they become
metaphors for what's happening in
present day a Song of Ice and Fire so
there are a lot of characters that have
loaded dialogue that might imply things
like when Melisandre says you are the
prince who is promised but if you
thought that was very important than the
brand stuff like the stuff that has said
in bran flashbacks by characters is
vastly more important than that so I
really feel like the bran flashbacks are
the most important storyline this year
just because they're giving you the real
story of what's going on let me know in
the comments though because we're
getting Robert's rebellion in Bryans
flashbacks where do you want them to go
next
and how long do you think it's gonna be
before Daenerys learns about the White
Walkers because she's been consumed with
this Dothraki marine slavers Bay plot
for the last couple of seasons she
hasn't said anything about White Walkers
or what's happening north of the wall
she's mostly concerned with solving her
immediate problems than bringing her
army and conquering Westeros she hasn't
said anything about a white Walker yet
so I'm hoping that bran starts
communicating with Tyrion or her small
council or Samwell somebody starts
telling Daenerys that there is a much
bigger problem north of the wall but
what's gonna happen tonight is I'll post
my episode 5 video after the episode
airs so be sure to subscribe to get that
there's also a new round of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video there's all kinds of crazy stuff
I'm actual
really excited because remember if
you're really upset that they haven't
answered a lot of big questions that
they've seen like they've done a pretty
good job of paying things off setting up
and paying things off during brands
flashbacks so if there's something that
they've teased they will probably pay it
off this season why you guys wait for my
video to post tonight you can click here
for my Rickon Stark Theory video and you
can click here for my episode 4 video
from last week thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight